[Music]
welcome to cloud on air
live webinars from google cloud we're
hosting webinars every tuesday my name
is wes and this is mchale
and today we'll be talking to you about
cloud tpus
you can ask questions at any time on the
platform and we've got googlers standing
by to answer them so let's get started
as wes mentioned we're here to talk
about the cloud the cloud tpu pod
a super computer for deep learning that
packs eleven and a half
petaflops of performance my name is
mikhail shresta i'm a machine learning
specialist within google cloud's
customer engineering team
and wes is our cloud tpu product manager
in terms of our agenda for today we'll
start with what
are tpus we'll move on to the why and
highlight a case study with ebay how
they're using cloud tpus
to enable visual search we'll then jump
into how and i'll walk through a short
demo of how you can access cloud tpus
today
on google cloud platform and wes will
conclude with a sneak peek into the
future of
the cloud tpu pods and we'll end with q
a
so wes let's jump right in and let's
start with around
what was the motivation behind
developing cloud tpus
yeah thanks so as you can see here on
this slide
this shows how models have increased in
size
and have increased in accuracy over
about the last five to six years and
this has been
really quite phenomenal how fast these
things have grown
the amount of compute needed to bring
this kind of performance
uh has been astounding and so from that
we realized that we needed to build
something that was more specialized
to deep learning yeah yeah very
interesting i guess
in today's current current landscape the
multi-purpose hardware accelerators they
might not be enough to really further
push
ai when we talk about new fields such as
autonomous systems
robotics and things that are very
important like safety and healthcare
where every percentage point really
matters and we want to get to 85
90 95 that's really where we believe
that specialized hardware
purpose built for ml can really advance
ai moving
forward so let's talk about exactly what
these hardware accelerators are and what
they look like
yeah so these are the tpus tensor
processing units and they're asics
and they're specifically designed to do
machine learning and asic
is application specific integrated
circuit and these are literally just
that
they're specifically designed to run
deep neural networks
and do the math that powers deep neural
networks
yeah so we see a lot of generations here
why didn't we stop at version one three
years ago
oh sure uh so in 2015 in the slide you
can see that we started with a very
simple
processor we wanted to see what we could
do with it this one specifically just
did inference
so already taking a trained model and
being able to output
what the computer thinks it's seeing and
we soon realized that this
this is amazing it's awesome it's a good
thing to keep pursuing
so we made tpu v2 and we increased the
amount of compute that it did
quite phenomenally to 180 teraflops and
then we
kept going tpu v3 that we just announced
uh 420 teraflops per device and you can
see on that device that there's four
chips
and they're all working together yeah
great so here here we have some
snapshots of exact
the chips but today we're really here to
talk about the pods so let's jump in and
really talk about the different
granularities all the different
methodologies
around using these yeah so there's some
terminology here
so we talk about unlike on that last
slide you can see here
with one board which has four chips on
it
and then as uh as you get into a larger
configuration that board is able to
talk to other boards and other chips in
a very high speed way so that they all
basically act like one accelerator and
then we call that full configuration a
full pod
where we can take 64 of those devices
and hook them all together and network
them in such a way that they're all
essentially acting like one and that's
that's where we get a full pod and then
we also offer the ability to do that in
smaller
chunks and we call those slices so it's
not all or nothing we do have the small
granularity the full pod but we have a
lot of different slice options
a quick question why not more
combinations or permutations of those
slices i see three here in the middle
right these are kind of the optimal way
that they can communicate together
so when you when we talk about like how
they do their actual matrix math
these are the optimal configurations in
which they can operate at full speed
i see so a lot of terminology we have
cores we have chips we have devices
slices
pods i think the key takeaway is really
around the number of cores that's really
the key metric
and that's where the naming convention
really follows when we have the v2
followed by the number of cores
available to you as an end user yeah
exactly so now let's dive in a little
bit into the low level what is actually
happening on these chips
right as we go down and we focus in on
one ship
this is kind of the heart of the tpu and
as you can see in this
animation that the matrix math is done
from one corner to the following corner
and this is how
this is how the the tpus function they
do very simple
linear algebra in matrix math and how
that is computed
is essentially like a heart would be
pumping blood and that's where the
systolic array gets its name
i see so they're not too versatile but
for matrix multiplication specifically
they're super fast
and i guess you see everyone should see
the tpudemo.com
feel free to take a look it actually has
a voiceover and a deeper explanation
around this visual
as well as comparisons across your more
traditional hardware such as cpus and
gpus
um so we are here to talk about full
pods so taking that performance that
watch just mentioned and really scaling
it up so wes can you talk about how this
scales up
yeah so hinted at this a little bit
earlier but this is how they communicate
at a full pod level to do
a propagation through each and every
parameter calculation
in a linear fashion so it scales
perfectly
so as you get up to a full pod you don't
have to change any code
all you have to do is increase your
batch size
i see and and hardware might be a little
bit intimidating but as
a data scientist and someone who focuses
on ml code what really makes me smile is
that line linear performance scaling
without code changes
so that's great where i can code once
and then scale seamlessly yeah
um so uh wes i think we're excited to
announce that these pods are available
to the broader community can you uh
take us into some of the specs yeah so
uh these pods are available today
and we have them in alpha and when you
utilize a full pod you can get about
11.5 petaflops of actual dnn compute
and your models can be extremely large
so up to four terabytes of high
bandwidth memory
and then of course they're all connected
in that 2d taurus
which basically means that every chip
kind of acts as one chip all together at
the same time
and there's and i should i should
mention that it's a training and
inference
oh yeah i mean this is fascinating is
one of the internal end users being able
to just log into a web browser
log into my google google cloud platform
account and to be able to provision a
full super computer
without worrying about capital
expenditures setting up the hardware
and being able to train these these
massive models it's really fascinating
we're really excited
to enable all our customers and partners
to be able to leverage these as part of
their ml processes as well moving
forward
so we'll jump now into a little bit of
the why around this and really around
the business applications and and first
off you know why pods
deep learning overall really takes a lot
of experimentation it's more of an art
as much as
as much as a science so when we talk
about pods right away the quick win
is rapid experimentation number two we
talked about this around
coding once and seamlessly scaling so
you're really a lot more productive as a
data scientist so
which allows you to amplify your work
across the organization
number two we're also at a point where
these models are getting very large and
very complex
not only can we not fit data on one
machine there are moments where we
actually can't fit the actual model on
the machine
we're getting to the point where there's
millions even billions of parameters so
being able to leverage
all these cores all this memory allows
us to experiment with very very large
models
in a lot of emerging spaces and finally
as a lot of industries and customers
move into more of a personalization
service really creating these rich
customer experiences
when we talk about recommendations
visual search localized translations for
each
region and even very important things
like medical transcriptions
that's really where we believe having
up-to-date fresh data
that really is able to stay intelligent
as your users evolve and their habits
change
it really gets you one step closer to a
continuous learning loop
uh moving forward so that's a little bit
around why why we truly believe that
pods can help out today
and how can you help out even how can
you start even sooner
so wes can you go over some of the
reference models that are readily
available and optimized for tpus
yeah so tpus have a set of
what we would call optimized models and
these are ones that are available on
github today
and they cover these four basic sections
of deep neural networks so that you can
do
pretty much whatever you want and you
can get started with these today
so these are all available on github and
you can do image recognition and object
detection
machine translation and language
modeling with transformer
as well as speech recogni recognition
and image generation
but you can see like for object
detection and recognition
we have various models uh available and
these these have been in the industry
you know as long as long as we've been
doing this
and it showed on that first graph that
we had yeah and while these
while these might be familiar names for
for folks who already immerse in the
deep learning space i do want to i do
want to dive a little bit into this for
folks who are just
just joining the deep learning community
in traditional
ml you usually just select a machine
learning technique you might choose
regression or classification
you might use a technique like random
force or decision trees
but there's one additional layer in the
process when you talk about deep
learning and that's actually
architecting these models and what this
is what these reference models are
referring to
how many layers deep is the model how
many nodes per layer
what is that what are the actual
properties for each of the nodes
are they short term long term are they
recurrent or not so when we talk
when we talk about names like amoeba net
inception transformer
these are actually ready to use models
that you can apply today to your
business problems
in the image space whether you're
looking at product quality on a factory
line or stock outs
on a physical floor space so i just want
to kind of clarify that these actually
are ready to use they're not just
machine learning techniques these are
fully architect architected models that
are ready to use on your data
and then moving forward we wanted to
highlight one customer that was an
early user of tpu pods ebay yeah
um so ebay came to us and they they
wanted to be able to speed up their
training
currently they had done a a massive
amount
of on-prem work and it took them quite a
while to do training
and sometimes even took months we were
able to
provide them with some
new model and new model support as well
as
some tpus and were able to increase
their training by
over a hundred x as well as increasing
their accuracy ten percent
which accuracy is kind of the name of
the game how how high can you get it
yeah and i mean the the performance
results are really amazing
but really let's talk about the size of
this you know why were tpu pods really
uh really useful here and if you look at
just the catalog listing of ebay
one of our one of one of the staples of
silicon valley one billion product
listings at this point
as well and for the test that we did
with them they actually ran a model on
55 million product images
and to be able to predict over 10 000
product categories so this is a very
very large scale problem
that would not be able to be solved
without custom hardware accelerators
yeah and the largeness of how much
memory is available on the tpu pods is
key
absolutely um so now let's jump into how
do you actually get started uh before we
dive into that i want to talk about
you know who is this for really how are
we positioning tpu pods
the easy answer might be this is for the
deep learning researchers and the data
scientists
and that answer is correct it's really
it's going to allow you to scale and
amplify your work
but really the broader mission of google
cloud is also to enable the developers
the data analyst the business analyst
the 20 plus million out there that want
to leverage machine learning
so tpus today if you know python
especially with these reference models
that wes mentioned
you can get started today on practical
pragmatic
business applications also we understand
that there
you might have already done a lot of
work on developing a ml infrastructure
we really want to make sure we have
minimum disruption so if you do want to
leverage tpu pods for
training large models you can still take
that model and still serve them
within your existing cpu or gpu serving
infrastructure
now how do we actually provision a tpu
pod everything is through google cloud
you log into the google cloud platform
console
and really actually it's just one
command there's a nice
utility tool where in this case it's
ctpu up
and then you specify the size that wes
mentioned anything from the normal tpu
device with eight cores all the way up
to a full pod of 512.
but what exactly does this ctpu up
command do
and it does a number of things number
one it's
it provisions a host vm a cpu this is
pre-installed with tensorflow
today it's with tensorflow version 1.12
but you can specify the version of your
needs
and what this what what the cpu actually
acts is
acts as as the tensorflow client this
has a tensorflow code
it actually serves up the tensorflow
graph to the tpu pod
it also takes all the images that are
stored in google cloud storage bucket
and feeds it into the tpu pod and the
tpu pod essentially acts
as the tensorflow server in this case
also while you're using this it's
important to note that tpu pods are
accessible through two apis currently
the tpu estimator and keras for those
who are
more familiar with that framework and
there's a number of tools that are
expanding around being able to monitor
and profile your tpu workloads tpu
profiler allows you to take a look at a
lot of metrics like utilization to make
sure that tpus are being used most
effectively
and tpu compatibility checker is a plug
into tensorboard with a screenshot in
the
right side of the slide to make sure
that your actual tensorflow code is
optimized for tpus
there's a great youtube video in the
bottom right from our colleague brennan
during the tensorflow dev summit that
talks a little bit more around all the
tools available to you
as you develop on tpu pods
so now uh we do want to walk you through
a practical demo
and first going through the end-to-end
demo architecture
so first we start with the raw images
and those are those are hosted on our
object storage web service called google
cloud storage
in this case i'll go through an example
around imagenet
second we really want to pre-process
data whether it be feature engineering
on
tabular data data augmentation for
images we want a quick way to get your
data ready for
for training and in this case also
converting to tf records and that's
really where apache beam
or our managed service on cloud data
flow comes in
finally once those once the data is
ready in google cloud storage
you submit that to the tpu pod using the
architecture
with the host vm and the tpu that i
mentioned before
and finally the model is outputted into
a storage bucket for you to
use as needed or even export and use it
as part of your current infrastructure
finally there's a lot of different
options to serve one of them is to serve
those models
on our serving infrastructure on cloud
machine learning engine this is a great
end-to-end pipeline and we also suggest
that you have
you have a method to orchestrate and
automate this using cloud composer which
is our managed apache airflow
solution and then if you were you were
watching the webinar before us with the
non-dun till around kubeflow pipelines
ai hub
really see a reference architecture like
this a great asset
to reuse across the organization so we
so we really are going to put in a lot
of work to take this pipeline with tpu
pods
and really add it into a kubeflow
pipeline and make it more discoverable
as part of the broader ai hub community
so now let's jump into the actual demo
so for those who are not familiar with
imagenet it is a image catalog
of indexed and labeled data that is
widely used within the research
community
in this case i'm going through a couple
examples here
and for those of you who who are big
disney fans i know the lion king is
coming up in 2009 so you have just a
quick example here
for the for the lion cub image we
actually have
over 16 1600 tagged images
of lion cubs but again i believe
imagenet at this point has
millions and millions of tagged images
across 20 000 categories
that is great for research and then you
can use a lot of these models and then
apply them onto your own custom data set
also i talked about
a lot of the pre-processing of the data
we actually have a lot of
a lot of tool kits available directly in
the tpu repo on github
to be able to do that things like
downloading the image imagenet data set
that i just talked about and
transforming it in tf records
done for you automatically if you have
your own images across your your
unique product catalog your unique
taxonomy there's actually a jpeg to tf
record python script that's readily
accessible for you
now let's let's jump in into google
cloud platform and i mentioned that with
one command
ctpu up you can actually provision a
host
host machine pre-installed with
tensorflow as well as a full tpu pod
this is the screen for google compute
engine where you have your vms
then we also take a look at the tpus
available here
here right now right now i have a
pre-installed
host vm with a tpu i'm actually going to
run a quick example just to show you how
quickly this can be done by anyone
and i'm going to bring up our quick
cloud shell this can also be run
on a local command line instance or your
local development environment where
the google cloud sdk is pre-installed
i'm going to run this command
and uh i won't wait for it to fully
fully provision but
as you can see already with one command
the cloud on air tpu vm host vm
is is being instantiated as we speak
now i'm going to actually ssh into an
existing
my existing virtual machine and to
really get started with the reference
models the only step you need to prepare
for is just cloning the github repo
in this case i'm cloning one of our
resnet models within the tpu model's
official repository and it comes
pre-installed with a lot of
a lot of files that are ready for you to
train and evaluate those models moving
forward
i'm going to quickly
uh move to google cloud storage bucket
i mentioned we are going to we are going
to save the model
in a google cloud storage bucket for you
to be able to monitor the usage as well
as
be able to export that as needed i will
create
models 8 as i have while testing here
as i prepare this prepare this model i'm
going to set some
environment variables
change this to eight
and i'm just going to run the training
the training python code again python is
what you need to get started
and really we're off to the races so
we're off to the races
if i scroll down i know we have a lot of
noise here but i just want to show you
one piece here where right away we've
noticed i've i've used a quarter pod
here
so it's uh it's realized there's 128
cores
16 tp workers available for me to train
this again i
the code is written for one tpu or all
the way up to a full pod here
and as i now go back to the new bucket
that i just created
now while all the magic is happening i
hit refresh this is where
the model training is occurring the
model file is going to be exported and
all the checkpoints for all the updated
variable weights are going to be saved
and i might just wait about 5-10 seconds
just to see one or two files there's the
graph that we're going to use
and we'll we'll continue to see the
checkpoints
continually be saved as we move forward
so that's how easy it was for me to get
started
i actually created uh i created the tpu
uh or provisioned a tpu i should say
with the ctpup command
i cloned the github repo and then i ran
the training job
now as i move forward i also might want
to look at what is my
performance here so i am going to
open up cloud shell one more time
and use one of my other buckets from a
previous model that i wrote to actually
run tensorboard
so we have tensorboard here i'm going to
bring up the ui
change the port and this will bring up
the tensorboard dashboard
this is a completed model that i had to
run earlier this morning
i took about 25 minutes to run through
and a couple of metrics around really
the power
of the tpu pod first the images per
second
fluctuated between about 66 000 images
per second to 68
000. so that's really utilizing the the
performance there
when we talk about the loss again
i i can see my my loss training and also
my final evaluation data point there
and seeing the loss increase up until
the optimal manner and most importantly
what what
what was my accuracy so accuracy can be
measured in a lot of ways i think in
image classification top one
or top five accuracy are are great
standard benchmarks
in this case as i zoom in the top one
accuracy for this example
along with the hover over was actually
76 percent
and top five accuracy if you're okay
with the right result being in one of
the top five
highly probable classes was actually 93
so moving back moving back to our our
slides here
um really i spun up a quarter pod was
able to get to
almost 68 69 000 images per second
utilizing the full tpu pod
reached the accuracy of 76 percent in
under 25 minutes
and overall west is going to talk about
the prices but it costs me less than 50
to do this this is quite fascinating
where this would not be possible just a
few years ago
right the 25 minutes is phenomenal and
that's just utilizing a quarter pod
and if you wanted to scale that up to a
full pod you can drop that linearly
yeah absolutely so let's dive in a
little bit more into the pricing and
what's available on gcp
yeah so you can see in the chart here we
start out if at the top
with tpu devices and you can see the
price for v2 and v3 there
and then all the other ones that are
kind of shaded in white and then down
down to the full pod there those are the
prices per hour
for each individual slice of of a pod
and honestly like when you when you
start to get
into like the quarter pod and half pod
and full pot arena
you're really focusing on time like
those times are going to be phenomenally
fast
so if you're if your business is
concerned about time
like those are the places that you want
to think about increasing the throughput
uh of
of your training absolutely
um so i think we we also wanted to get
give you a sneak peek into the future so
wes can you talk about some of the new
upcoming items
on cloud tpu yeah and um if you know
we talked about earlier how the models
that are currently supported
are out on github that we also have an
experimental section
and you'll see some of these already in
the experimental section
so data parallelism uh with distribution
strategy
as well as pi torch support these are
all coming
in the very near future and tf
tensorflow 2.0
is going to have a lot of extended
functionalities for tpu
and so with that stay tuned for live q a
and we'll be back in less than a minute
great welcome back everyone so we're
going to go through a couple of
questions from the audience
the first question is how do i get
access to tpu pod
as wes mentioned we're announcing that
they are available to the public today
if you go on our public tpu
documentation website you'll see the
instructions there
also um feel free to reach out to a
google account team and we'll get you
access
from a tactical standpoint there might
be steps for you to go into your google
cloud platform project
and request quotas if you really want
access to
uh to a high number of course yeah
second question
can you run custom models on tpu pods
we've gone through a lot of this session
talking about reference models
ready ready to use models in the spaces
of image
language and video but yes you can run
custom models on tpu pods
there are certain libraries within the
tensorflow framework tpu rewrite and tpu
estimator that allow you to
port over your existing tensorflow
models into models that
run efficiently on tpu pods they just
take a little bit of extra work
cool yeah yeah so next question is what
are petaflops
so when we think about like really large
compute we start talking about how
big and how fast they go so when you
talk about a flot
that's a floating point operation per
second
and when you talk about a petaflop
you're talking about a thousand
teraflops
so that when you go and you do this
compute
you can do it that much faster so it's
just large
large scale super computing and the next
step up from that is exaflop
so right now with tpu pods we're at 11.5
petaflops
so that's the amount of throughput that
you're able to get with your matrix math
and let's see uh and then the next one
starting at the smallest tpu
size what changes do i need to make to
scale to a tpu pod
well that we've made that very simple
and on that one slide we talked about
how there's no code changes
the basic change that you have to make
is batch size and that's because the
memory is increasing so you want to
increase the batch size
and that's how you keep the tpu pod
fully loaded
so every time that systolic array goes
and starts chunking through all of your
all of your uh layers and your dnn it's
going to always be
full of data and so that's that's that's
how you that's how you get
all the way up to a full pod so changing
the batch size that's a great point
code changes for the actual training
code minimal to none but you might want
to look into changing the
hyperparameters to
fully utilize the larger larger slices
yeah and uh last question here um how
much of google's infrastructure is
running on tpus
well as you've probably seen over the
past couple years as you start
talking to things that google makes a
little bit more
we're doing actually quite a bit on tpus
it's so much more efficient
power efficient compute efficient and
density wise
that we're able to pack so much more
compute into
into our data centers so for cloud tpus
that's something that that we run most
of what you see
uh for machine learning uh on the
products that you use today
and for resources you can
go to these links here yeah absolutely
the
the first link is really our public tpu
documentation and also answer the
question of how do i get access to tpus
so those will be the instructions the
second link is a great
slide deck from our developer relations
team that's been put together
tpudemo.com talks a little bit around
the
the low-level architecture of tpus and
compared to other traditional hardware
accelerators
and finally the github repo that gives
you access to a lot of our official
optimized models
experimental models and a lot of those
toolkits that allow you to
pre-process your data to be fully
utilized by tpu pods
yeah uh stay tuned for the next session
how to build custom data visualizations
in data studio and thank you very much
thank you so much